Adam Levine was supporting his wife
Behati Prinsloo last night at the
Victoria Secret Fashion Show and they
look so great together she looks amazing
he's always been very supportive of her
they have been married for four years
yeah I have two beautiful children
together and she still looks great you
see those ABS honey yes
get it together dylan sprouse was there
supporting that Barbara Palvin with
Khalifa and Winnie Harlow
but the real party though the real party
and the real story is the after-party
that just kept heating up I was online
all day day because true story I love
the Victoria Secret Fashion Show I think
it's one of the most joyous things of
the holiday season and so I like to see
every tidbit I can about it but the
after party was great Bella Bella Hadid
Bella was there killed it killed it kill
a lot of people were saying they looks
hotter at the after-party than they
actually did on on stage on the runway
because these looks were amazing you are
so sexy and everybody had different
styles different versions
yeah they looks great that's bellos Ana
Julia McDonald change dress with new
boots on heels Gigi Hadid I did wore
Atelier Versace catsuit giving us like
throwback that was her first her first
Victoria Secret runway yeah and then
also GG right there
Bella other angels were just stunning
but you know that's what you do because
the stuff they were on the runway isn't
something gonna wear in real life right
that but get this - so my theory you're
not even a sillier theory but they've
been dieting for so long for this runway
show so now is there time to be as sexy
as I can possibly be so their looks are
on point it shows their bodies their
figures their glow they deserve this
night and I'm pretty sure they ate pizza
some of them had to eat people well
right after the show Barbara Palvin was
given Shake Shack by by her girl by her
boyfriend oh and sprouts oh yeah does
that been six years since you put it on
the runway so she was making her
triumphant return that's amazing
she did it's really good in coal on not
cold but dylan sprouse actually stood up
and gave her a standing ovation as she
was walking down the runway talk about
supportive well you have a man that
supports you know what you do
literally wholeheartedly like he gets
just as excited about it as you do it's
nothing like it right who's saying you
better work boo work that's my girl
the returns of your Fashion Show holiday
special airs on December 2nd on ABC
[Music]